نداء يائس للمساعدة من فتاة تبلغ من العمر
ست سنوات مذعورة محاصرة في
سيارة كل من حولها ميتون هند كانوا
في السيارة مع عمها وزوجته
وأطفالهم الأربعة يحاولون الفرار من
القتال من هذا الجزء من شمال غزة
الرعب في ذلك  سيارة استولت عليها في هذا
النداء طلباً للمساعدة من ابن عمها الذي سجله
الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني،
مرحباً
مرحباً أيها الأقارب، تلقت صباح يوم الاثنين
اتصالاً من العائلة يخبرهم أنهم
تعرضوا لنيران الجيش الإسرائيلي
اتصلت بي "ر" وقالت عمي والدي وأمي
وأختي و  لقد قتل أخي أنا
أنزف ساعدوني أنا أموت قلت لها
اربطي نفسك بأي شيء في الساعة 400 مساءً.  لقد
ماتت ولم يبق إلا
الطفلة هند قالت من فضلك أنا صغيرة أنا
مجروحة لقد تبولت على
نفسي بقيت على الهاتف مع
الهلال الأحمر
لساعات ما هذا الوقت قالت لقد
حل الظلام أنا خائفة
كانت المنطقة المظلمة خطيرة للغاية ويصعب الوصول إليها،
وكان عليهم إبقاء h على الهاتف بينما كانوا
يتدافعون لمحاولة إيصال فريق
إليها حيث تم إرسال فريق أخيرًا،
وكان طبيب نفساني الآن على الهاتف مع
h ولكن بعد أيام كانوا  ما زلنا ننتظر
اللقاء، فقد الهلال الأحمر كل اتصال
بهند ومتطوعيه اللذين
تم إرسالهما للعثور عليها، وقد أعطت شبكة سي إن إن
للجيش الإسرائيلي تفاصيل حول
الحادث بما في ذلك الإحداثيات التي قدمها الهلال
الأحمر الفلسطيني.
نحن
قلقون للغاية، نحتاج إلى معرفة ما حدث،
هل تمكنوا من إنقاذ أيديهم، هل تم
القبض عليهم، هل نجوا، نحتاج إلى
إجابات، لا أحد يائس للحصول على
إجابات أكثر من والدة هين المذهولة،
إذا لم تمت ابنتي من
الرصاص الذي ستموت منه
البرد من الجوع قالت ابنتي
ماما أنا
جائعة قالت ماما أنا عطشان أنا أشعر
بالبرد أناشد العالم كله أن
يعيدني يا ابنتي أريد أن يتصل أي شخص
بالجيش نريد
فتاتنا الصغيرة البريئة هند أيضًا  صغيرة
جدًا على أن تمر بهذا، إنها صغيرة جدًا، لقد
ذهب الكثير من الشباب في هذه الحرب، لكن
عائلة واحدة تتمسك بالأمل في ألا يكون
الوقت قد فات لإنقاذ
تلميحهم الصغير جاما كاراتش سي إن إن
لندن